texas senator ted cruz uh explains now
first of all i think people need to know
how many times did you argue before the
supreme court
nine times
okay how many times you win
uh five of them
okay but you took on tough cases to be
fair to you alan dershowitz says some of
the biggest landmark cases in the
country
alan dershowitz harvard professor said
you're one of his best students that
he's ever had the opportunity to teach
you guys don't agree on a whole lot
um all right let's go to this case
specifically why is this such a big win
well listen if you look at federal
campaign finance law what what congress
has done the number one priority for
congress is to prevent anyone from
beating them and and so this law it
limits the ability of a candidate to
make a loan to his or her campaign and
then pay himself back and and the reason
that incumbent politicians want to do
that is they don't want anyone to
challenge them that they don't want some
pesky challenger let's say some small
business owner
to make a loan to put their life savings
in and to knock out the career
politician and so they put this
cap in place that said all right if you
loan money to your campaign
you're out of luck we're going to limit
how much you can pay yourself back and
everything above that tough luck it's a
gift to the american people and and what
the supreme court said in this case 6-3
i brought a lawsuit challenging this
and 6-3 the supreme court agreed with me
and said this is unconstitutional this
abridges free speech and and the
consequence of that is this is going to
make it a lot easier for challengers to
take on career politicians the the
existing rule benefited incumbent
politicians and it benefited the super
rich and and the result of this decision
today is it becomes a lot easier for
citizens to say all right i'm fed up
with the direction our country is going
and and and i'm gonna go campaign and
throw the bums out and the more of that
you have the the stronger our democracy
is
clarence thomas i'll leave the court
when i do my job as poorly as you do
yours how
you got to love clarence thomas uh he's
always had a great sense of humor smart
as hell i think one of the great
justices of all time
and i i love that answer what's your
reaction
well listen justice thomas is is a great
american hero i know him well the left
is trying to demonize him and attack him
one of the things i love about justice
thomas he's got that big booming laugh
it's almost like santa claus oh
by the leftists that are coming after
him and and you know what he just said
there that you aired a second ago is is
this leak at the supreme court
was the radical left trying to destroy
our supreme court it went right to the
heart of the trust in that institution
and by the way
i'm convinced it was a leftist law clerk
who leaked it
in order to bully and pressure the
justices to change their vote and why do
you believe that
because it's consistent with the
democrat pattern for years of
politicizing and undermining and
attacking the judiciary and the supreme
court trying to politicize it and you
look at who celebrated the leak it was
the hard left that celebrated the leak
the incident happened
immediately after the leak you saw
left-wing groups publicizing the home
addresses of the justices and we're now
seeing angry left-wing protesters going
to the justices homes trying to
terrorize them trying to threaten them
listen someone comes to your home
that's where your children are that's
that's where you and your spouse sleep
and and you know there is a federal
statute that makes it a crime
to protest at the home of a judge while
a case is pending because they don't
want people threatening judges in the
administration of justice
merrick garland joe biden's attorney
general refuses to prosecute these
left-wing prosecutors
and the white house is is is giving the
green light
to threatening and trying to intimidate
the justices as justice thomas said just
a minute ago it's hard to think of an
institution in our country the left is
not trying to destroy and we need to be
bringing back these institutions to
protect our constitution and to protect
the bill of rights it's just like the
democrats only care about one riot but
called 574 of them in the summer of 2020
mostly peaceful uh billions of property
damage dozens of dead people thousands
of injured cops uh
obviously we all care about buffalo but
they never mention the every weekend uh
violence in many major cities like
chicago ever
very selective moral outrage senator
thank you appreciate you being with us